tai lopez just tried ruining nfts with
his unique brand of knowledge well
technically nfts were kind of already
ruined but he tried to make it worse by
selling a chance to win ten thousand
dollars in a one-on-one basketball game
all you have to do is pay fifty thousand
dollars if that's not your thing how
about watching a movie with tai lopez
for only thirty thousand dollars but
just know you're not going to be the one
to pick it this black card gets you
access being you one on one maybe an
assistant or two or my business partner
or compiler you'll be the only og card
holder going we go to the movies i'll
pick a good movie i mean my guy wants to
make you pay 30 grand but still wants to
pick the movie ladies and gentlemen this
is without a doubt the worst nft cash
grab i've ever seen at one point tai
lopez during his launch claims to have
crashed the entire ethereum blockchain
we crashed the whole damn blockchain in
like four
took four minutes to crash it now
obviously that's not true tai lopez has
nothing to do with ethereum's slow
transactions and high fees the culprit
is actually someone else entirely but
regardless of how bad it looks i promise
it gets worse under the surface and
ironically this whole project might be
backfiring on tai due to promises he
made which he now has to go through with
which include him having to buy a hotel
restaurant and nightclub that only i can
go to because yes ladies and gentlemen i
did pick up one of these nfts so you
don't have to so we can see this train
wreck through to the end now will i get
scammed probably which is why i need you
to pump zilla boyce the the warchest is
getting shockingly low i mean we can't
even afford tai lopez's netflix and
chill card at this point and frankly i'm
embarrassed okay i'm embarrassed for all
of us we're at the lower tier trust me
we're like
one level the cheapest then we're like
one level above that but for anyway for
context the reason i'm doing all this is
because we already did this once with
tai lopez's 67 step program but today
it's a bit different the idea is
basically that i can only cover these
scams so much from the outside every now
and then i like to infiltrate to the
inside and see these scams from the
perspective
of a victim and since tai is moving away
from courses and into crypto i knew this
is one i wanted to follow now i want you
guys to remember that this isn't tai's
first attempt into crypto he's already
tried selling radio shack crypto tokens
which went about as well as radio shack
stores actually but now he's taking
another swing at things with the tai
lopez nfts which he's calling the
original garage social club now what is
this about tai lopez says that he's not
doing art nfts like monkey jpegs instead
these are utility nfts meaning that they
give you access to real world things for
example there's three levels silver gold
and black and at the lowest level you
get access to a bunch of defunct courses
that tai lopez used to sell and now just
bundles together then slightly above
that is access to something thai calls
the og nft hotel restaurant and club
membership which is exactly what it
sounds like a membership to an exclusive
hotel restaurant and club and then from
here is where things get increasingly
bizarre for example you can pay 72 000
to go to a michelin star restaurant with
tai where he graciously says he'll pick
up the bill although he draws the line
at paying for your travel to get there
which i mean is almost funny how greedy
that is and this is the kind of goofy
thing that all of these nfts have
they're all these strange fine print in
them that make them even worse than they
seem like for instance one of them is
one-on-one whatsapp access to ty's
personal number which costs an
astonishing 90 000
but it gets worse because there's fine
print that says you can actually only
ask him one question per month which is
almost hilarious like
what can you get done the first time you
go hey how's it going and then next
month you're like um i'm actually good
what are you doing with my 90 000 right
now but i have to say as bad as that is
there's actually one that makes all of
these look like a bargain next to it and
that's the one-on-one private jet flight
with tai lopez okay let me set the stage
for you guys because this is going to
take a second we got to really unpack
this this is a 90 000 card and i just
want you to listen to ty describe this
this is the worst experience i've ever
heard of if you
want to come on a really cool experience
that's guaranteed like me focused come
on a jet with me private jet it's just
like right there
i'm here with you you meet me at the
private
jet location where we're taking off
we'll fly we'll talk
we land and boom you can see where i'm
going this is a pretty cool one so quick
recap tai lopez wants you to pay 90 000
for the privilege of having him take you
on a one-way flight and then leave you
on a tarmac stranded away from major
airports your only hope i guess is that
you haven't used your one question of
the month so maybe you can ask them how
the hell you get back that ladies and
gentlemen is where we're at with nfts
and i know what you're thinking this is
insane how could anyone buy this well
you're actually right about that for the
first time in the history of nfts even
the degens of crypto saw this and said
yeah this is pretty dumb and overpriced
even for us and this is where we get to
the first good news of the day this nft
sold horribly only 10
of the total amount was sold that is a
total failure i mean even squiggles did
better than that which of course isn't
to say that tai lopez made nothing he
raked in 1.3
million dollars but there could be bad
news here for ty as well because he
promised something that may end up
screwing him later on this little silver
card could cause problems which we've
already talked about this is the nft
hotel restaurant and club membership it
was a few hundred dollars to mint and it
was supposed to be one of 8 000 nfts
which promised access to the first ever
nft hotel restaurant and club basically
the pitch was if you hold this card you
get exclusive access to these places
that nobody else is allowed to stay at
unless they have this card and it's very
explicit only nft holders will have
access to this hotel now the problem
here is almost nobody minted this thing
only 560 people in total which means tai
lopez is contractually obligated to buy
or build a hotel bar and restaurant
which has a total customer base of 500
people total and if it's not obvious
that's just not enough people to do that
kind of thing for i mean hotels cost
millions of dollars at the low end and
this thing only has a customer base of
like 500 people which is maybe gonna get
you one or two customers a day if you're
lucky so this nft thing which was
supposed to be this huge cash grab for
tai lopez might end up being a disaster
for him which i personally find
hilarious and that's actually why i
bought a pass on the secondary market
once i knew this thing flopped so that
if this ever becomes a reality like a
real hotel i'm gonna give you a live
stream from the worst hotel in the world
a hotel that literally only 560 people
can stay at and they're all tai lopez
fans which i think just sounds like a
fascinating and horrible experience now
to the skeptics out there who think tai
lopez is probably just gonna run away
with the money at this point and not do
any of this you're probably right but i
just want to be there for whatever
happens to document the disaster all
right that's basically it subscribe for
more knowledge